- [DRock] Wait,
so what happened?
What did you say on Snapchat?
- [Gary] I just put three
pictures of the place I sent.
- [DRock] Not like, "Hey,
let's meetup," or anything?
- Three pictures.
- [DRock] Yeah, that's nuts.
("Always" by Jura Kez)
- [Ryan] GaryVee!
- [Gary] 'Sup guys?
- [Usama] Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] How are you, man?
What's your name?
- Usama.
- [Gary] Usama, how are you?
- Good.
- [Gary] How'd you guys,
how'd you guys find this?
- Do you really want to know?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Snapchat, Instagram, Twitter.
- [Gary] What'd I put out? Yeah?
- You posted a picture
of the restaurant inside.
- [Gary] And you figured it out?
- We went on Google Maps
and went through
every single restaurant--
- [DRock] (laughs) That's...
- on the street
and I saw the blue
lighting and the drapes
and we found you here.
- [Gary] I'm impressed,
baby. Good fuckin' work.
- Being persistent.
- [Gary] I love it, I love it.
I love it.
- [DRock] How many
restaurants did you go through?
- Oh, well we live in the area.
We're down the street.
- We knew it was
somewhere along this area.
He noticed RBC building.
- I actually take this
way to go to work every day.
- And we live down
the street there, man.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- We had to come meet you.
- [Gary] Hey.
- Hey.
- [Gary] How are you?
- I was the one
who Greyhounded here.
- [Gary] I saw
your Greyhound picture.
That's fucking crazy, man.
Where are you coming from?
I'm coming from Waterloo.
- [Gary] And how
far away is that?
- [Usama] 45 minutes to an hour.
- It's like two hours on a bus.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- [Ryan] On a bus,
it's more, yeah.
- I run a small
startup so I thought
I had to come pitch it to you.
- [Gary] Thank you.
Hey, man. How are you?
- Arslan, nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Arslan,
nice to meet you, man.
- Been following you all day.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Didn't get a chance to go to--
- [Gary] The conference?
- the conference unfortunately.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Getting married so lot to do.
- [Gary] Oh, congratulations.
Congratulations.
Awesome.
Hey man.
- Hey, how's it going?
I can't believe you're here.
(group laughter)
I live like two
blocks down the road,
I'm just kinda like--
- [Gary] You're like,
"I know where that
is. I'll go." Awesome.
Well, cool. You want
to take a quick photo?
I know you guys
have been waiting.
- [Usama] Yes.
- [Gary] I need to
get back into my meeting.
I'm actually, I actually
did post this stuff just now
but I'm going back in
for at least 15 minutes.
I was like in 15 minutes,
maybe somebody will show up.
- [Ryan] Alright, what
sign are we doing, Gary?
(group cheers)
- [Man] Gary!
- [Gary] Hey man.
Want to take a picture.
- [Man] Yes.
- [Gary] Let's go, let's do it.
- [Man] I got one
question for you, man.
- [Gary] Yes?
- [Man] I'm an entrepreneur.
I always invest and
I never get tired of it.
When is it enough to
invest and when do you know
you shouldn't take money out of
your existing business
to put on another one?
- [Gary] That's
a tough question.
Take it again.
- [Man 2] Gary, where's Rick?
- [Gary] I don't
know where Rick is.
I want to kill Rick.
(group laughter)
It's tough, man. I didn't invest
in Uber in the Angel round
'cause I was tired of
investing in everything.
- Right.
- And it cost me $400 million.
- [DRock] Hey guys, watch out.
- [Gary] So there's no right,
there's no right answer.
- [Man] Right.
You just got to feel it.
- [Gary] You gotta feel it.
- Got it.
- [Gary] I'm not gonna
be able to answer that for you.
But, you can't
invest in everything.
If I invested in everything that
ever was pitched to me,
I'd be fucking out of,
I'd be homeless on
the corner around here.
Cool, man. Thanks for coming.
- Thanks a lot, brother.
I appreciate it.
- [Gary] Thanks for coming.
Thanks for all of you coming.
- [Gary] Hey man.
- Gary, I'm Marty.
Marty Sieson, I just
want to say thank you.
You and Casey from
New York have inspired me
and I'm sure a
lot of people here.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- Be real, be honest
and just work hard.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
- I just can't thank
you enough for that.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
- I just have one question.
- [Gary] Yep?
- As a hustler, is it okay to
take a day off every week?
- [Gary] Of course.
I take four hours
off every Sunday in the fall.
(group laughter)
Of course. I mean,
look, my big thing and
I think it's good to have
you guys here for clarity,
I'm no so worried if
you take four days off.
I'm just worried about
what you do when you're on.
I always tell people like,
that's why I did the
Arianna Huffington episode.
I want people to sleep.
I sleep. Sleep's important.
I sleep five or six or
seven hours, not one or two.
People get caught up in
the romantic point
of view of these things.
You can take 10, I took two
weeks off in August just now
as a lot of you guys know.
First of all,
we're all different.
I have a lot of natural energy.
My brother has, as
some of you may know
if you read what he
wrote when he left Vayner,
AJ has Crohn's Disease, right?
Which drains him so
he can't work that way.
The way I do it
or Casey or this guy,
we're all different.
The punchline though
is if you're complaining
and you aren't working
as hard as you possibly can,
that's the problem.
Complaining that you're not
getting yours or it hasn't
happened and having enough time
to play Pokemon GO or Madden
or watch "House of Cards,"
that's a problem.
But if you're fucking
grinding and you need a day to
be with your boyfriend
or girlfriend or your family
or just to fucking
veg out, that's fine.
Of course, that's fine.
And most importantly,
who am I to say?
Everybody's got to do them.
My big thing is, one thing
I haven't done a good job of,
that I've been talking
to DRock and team about is
a lot more of the things
that I want to do is like
if you complain, and
then go into my rant.
Like, I don't know.
I have friends that make
$42,000 a year, work 9 to 5
and are fucking pumped.
They're the last
people that I'm talking to.
They're happy.
But for so many people,
why so many of you are here,
you know, if you're
hungry for something,
I hope you understand that if
you're hungry to have this
or have great shit or you're
gonna buy the Maple Leafs
or talk shit like that,
you have to fuckin' work.
- [Man 2] Go Leafs!
- [Gary] Awesome, man.
- [Man 3] Gary, can I
ask you a quick question?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- So, first of all, your content
is awesome to the point
that I watch it every day
and not to weird you out
but popped up in my dreams
(group laughter)
how deep, so deep.
Yeah, DRock, you know.
- [Gary] You dream
about it, DRock?
You dream about me?
(group laughter)
I love you, brother.
I love you.
- [Man 2] Nothing weird,
nothing weird but that's...
So, I'm all about content.
I'm a digital strategist so
I look at the whole online
presence and I help businesses
get business results--
- [Gary] Yep.
- with online presence.
What I struggle with is how to
scale but also do I specialize?
Because I'm generalist by nature
and I'm fascinated
by social, search,
the whole gamut of content.
- [Gary] Then that's
what you should do.
- Right.
- [Gary] Just 'cause somebody
else has had a success
in going deep in something.
Like, I continue to
invest in things and
am crazy in
startup shit randomly.
Because you've got to
reverse engineer yourself.
- [Man 2] Right.
- Just 'cause somebody said,--
- [Man 2] Everybody
on the internet they're like,
"Well, we live in this world.
You gotta specialize."
- [Gary] I don't believe that.
- Right. Okay.
- [Man] Nice.
- [Gary] You have to understand,
you also have to
know how you function.
Like I know that 30%
of shit I do is gonna fail
and I'm gonna lose
money and waste time
but I need to do that
to make the other 70% go
because I can't just
concentrate and go deep.
I need to get my
entrepreneurial nut off.
You know? And so, that's
just the way it's gonna be
and the net
score of my 70 working
and throwing money and
time in the trash on the 30
is gonna be greater
than other people's 100
'cause that's how I function.
- [Man 2] So if
I'm fascinated with
all industries, all businesses--
- [Gary] Fucking go.
- [Man 2] Just do it, right?
- [Gary] Go, yeah.
- [Man 2] Okay. Can I
take a quick photo with you?
- [Gary] Yeah, let's do it.
- [Man 2] Would one of you guys
mind doing that for me?
- [Man 3] Yeah,
let me take it for you.
- [Man 2] Thanks, Gary.
- [Gary] You got it, brother.
- [Man 3] Done.
- [Gary] Can you
guys do me a favor
'cause I have to go to
something else at some point
'cause there's so many of you?
Why don't we do pictures
and signatures real fast
and then whoever
wants to hang and like have
deep fuckin' philosophical
theses. Yeah, let's do it.
(indistinct chatter)
Got it. I'll hang for that, too.
- [Man 4] In a world
where nobody's doing it,
how do you convince customers to
actually start
e-commerce and get into it?
- [Gary] It's hard.
Guys, can you
let this guy through?
Cool.
You don't.
You can't convince people.
- [Man 4] Gotta
convince yourself.
- [Gary] No, you gotta
basically just ask everybody
and then have
somebody break through.
- [Man 4] Alright,
'cause there's so much
complaining from all the
competitors--
- [Gary] I get it. I get it.
- but you know you can provide
something so much better.
- [Gary] I get it.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] What too many
people do is try to spend
too much time, it's kinda like
what I'm trying to do right now.
Instead of
answering every question,
let me just get to as many
people as poss,--
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- and then too many people
when they sell, they
want to like go so deep
and meanwhile there was
so much else to be done.
I think one of the biggest
reasons I'm a good salesman is
I'm never interesting
in convincing anybody.
I've always sold things
that nobody believed in.
E-commerce in 1996,
social media in 2006.
People didn't believe in it.
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- [Gary] I just didn't care.
I had no time for
you to convince you.
My whole
punchline was always like,
cool, I'll see
you in 2016. You know?
(indistinct chatter)
- [Gary] What's that?
- [Mohamed] My biggest strength?
- [Gary] What is
your biggest strength?
- [Mohamed] Yeah.
- [Gary] You're asking me what
your biggest strength is?
I'd probably say
fucking tenacity.
(group laughter)
- [Mohamed] Yeah.
- [Gary] What's your name?
- Mohamed.
- [Gary] M?
- [Mohamed] M-O-H-A-M-E-D.
Thank you so much.
- [Gary] You're welcome, man.
Good luck to you, man.
Let's take a photo.
I'll be right there, bro.
- Good. How do you
separate your personal brand
versus your external brand?
So to give you an example,--
- [Gary] Mark? M-A?
- [Mark] M-A-R-K, yeah.
- promote a personal brand
like yourself.
Like you have VaynerMedia,--
- [Gary] Yes.
- and you have Gary Vaynerchuk.
- How do you
distinguish the two?
How do you keep them separate
without trying to
get them intertwined?
- [Gary] I don't worry
about it whatsoever.
People overthink
that shit all the time.
VaynerMedia's a company.
It has 700 employees.
If somebody's confused
and sometimes they are,
a CMO of a big
company will come in and say,
"Hey, I want you."
I'm like, "There's no me.
I'm not for sale.
"There's VaynerMedia.
"You'll have Rick and
Steve and Susan and Carla."
And that's it, right?
- [Man 5] Don't say Rick!
- [Gary] You know what I mean?
So, I just explain
it when it matters.
- Awesome.
- [Man 6] When are
you buying the Jets?
- [Gary] One day, man.
I'm not worried about when.
Thanks, Mark. I wish
you well, man. Yeah.
- Hi.
- [Woman] Hi.
- [Gary] How are you?
- Nice to meet you.
- [Woman] Can I ask
you a couple questions?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Woman] How do you
go through you dreams
when you're dealing with a
parent going with the depression
and you have to
spend your time with them?
You don't want
to abandon them.
- [Gary] It's tough.
It's what I did the
first 10 years of Wine Library.
What people don't know is how
much time I spent with my dad.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- I get it.
The answer is I don't know.
For me to answer that question
for you is just inappropriate
because it's such a challenge.
What I will say is this,
and this is what kind
of changed my behavior
you're gonna
regret it so much and
you're gonna take it
out on them eventually.
- [Woman] If I don't go for it?
- [Gary] Of course.
You're gonna wake
up at 50, 60 and 70
and blame your parent
for the time they took up
where you didn't do your thing
and you're gonna eventually
make that relationship worse.
So what I did was I
chipped away at it, one by one.
I used to spend three hours a
day in his fucking office
and be his psychiatrist.
Then it became two.
Then it became
an hour and a half.
You're gonna have
to figure that out
because either you're
living your life for yourself
or you're living
it for somebody else.
- [Woman] Alright.
- I'm saying that
very empathetically.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- 'Cause we all have
different situations but
it's just black and white.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- There's no, there's nothing
I could tell you other
than you're gonna wake up
in 30 years and you're
gonna blame everything
that you did not
accomplish on them
for taking up all that time.
- [Woman] And that
regret is gonna be
bigger than the regret
of abandoning them?
- Correct. I think so.
- [Woman] You think so?
- I think so because
I don't think you have
to fully abandon them.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- But you need to find,
you need to make
sure that the cadence
of the amount of hours
you put in isn't too great.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- You know?
You also have your
whole life to live.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- I don't know what
your family situation
is but I look at like
what's my responsibility to
my children versus my parents
to myself to my spouse.
There's a lot of variables.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Man 7] What you did today,
the $50,000, I lived in
(inaudible) my whole life
so me with (inaudible), I know
exactly where he's coming from.
Me, a lot of people tell me
like, for me that's motivation.
That's another 'cause never in
my, you can take a picture--
- [Gary] Let's do it.
- while we talk 'cause I know
other people need to get a shot.
But, my whole life,
I worked three jobs there.
Pushing buggies, all that.
So you doing that, I want
to get in touch with James
and help him out.
- [Gary] He's on Twitter.
You can see him,
you can find him.
Good luck to you, man.
Good luck, man.
- Alright, thanks.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you, man.
- [Man 7] Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Yeah, stay well.
What's your name?
- Martin.
- [Gary] Martin.
- I had a quick question.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- Okay, I'm a
music producer, right?
- [Gary] Okay.
- I started about a year ago.
Lot of Crush It!,
hustled my ass off.
22,000 subscribers on
YouTube, thanks to you.
- [Gary] Good for you, man.
- I got you to thank.
- [Gary] Thanks to you.
You listened.
- Straight up, man.
I'm reaching that
ceiling where it's like
I'm trying to get my
beats to major artists
but it's so hard, right?
I feel like I have talent.
I could be working with J Cole
or Fat Joe, all those guys.
20,000 subscribers, it's hard to
get in contact with those guys.
- [Gary] You got to be patient.
- [Martin] How
would you recommend?
- [Gary] Cold email them.
- [Martin] Yeah?
Shit works.
- [Martin] That's it, eh?
- [Gary] Yeah,
if they like your shit.
People are
looking for beats. Always.
- [Martin] Yeah.
- [Gary] And they'll,
all the guys at the top,
and I know a lot of them,--
- [Martin] Yeah.
- [Gary] They'll
always spec listen.
- [Martin] Okay.
- [Gary] Sure, because their
game is finding the next shit.
- [Martin] Okay.
- [Gary] So no
matter how big they are,
you just have to hustle 'em.
Hit them up on social,
hit them up on email. Yeah.
- Taking on a
social mission stuff.
We have the center
for social innovation,
we have a lot of
(inaudible) going on,
how do you see as a social
entrepreneur taking
on that market?
- Thanks, man.
- Meaning social cause?
- Yeah, like social
cause entrepreneurship.
- [Man 8] So kind of
like how Kind Bar did it.
- [Gary] So, I think
most of those companies are
straight full of shit and use,
(group laughter)
I'm being serious.
- Yeah?
- [Gary] I think
all the people that
follow TOMS Shoes
and were like,
"Oh, if you buy one hat,
"I give some kid in
fuckin' Uganda a hat,"
and then they mark up the hats
enough to pay for the give--
- [Man 8] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- are straight fuck faces.
So, I think that
social good is great
and people should do it
and I actually don't think
there's any difference in
marketing a company that's got
good DNA versus a company
that's just in it for the dollar.
I genuinely don't
believe that Kind Bar
has any fundamental different
marketing strategy
than Snickers.
The difference is
that if they're smart
and they get their story in
front of people that give a shit
about what Kind Bar talks about,
it becomes a variable
to what they can sell.
But the strategy at the
North Star is not different.
- [Man 8] Hmmm.
- What they're
saying is different.
- [Man 9] Preach.
- [Man 8] Amazing.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Man 8] Thanks a lot, eh.
- Cool, man. Good luck to you.
- [Man 8] Appreciate it.
- [Gary] Dude!
Dude, how many
fucking Snapchat
Stories do you want?
- [Man 10] I love you.
- [Gary] We're on our
fuckin' seventh Snapchat.
- [Man 10] I was in bed but--
- [Gary] I do too but fuck.
- [Man 10] I saw you,
I came out.
- [Gary] Jesus.
- [Man 10] I was in bed.
I love Gary, guys.
- [Gary] I love you, too.
Alright,
I'll see you guys later.
If you're talking
video, it's all Facebook.
- [Woman 2] For
web series content?
- [Gary] Yes. Yes.
- [Woman 2] Okay.
- [Gary] Facebook is
substantially bigger
and has more
upside than YouTube.
- [Woman 2] Okay, cool.
- [Gary] Yeah.
Deep, deep, deep.
Yeah, let's do it fast.
Hurry, this guy's
gonna run you over.
Bye guys. Love you. Thank you.
Thanks for coming out.
I love you guys.
Thank you.
Ooph.
("Always" by Jura Kez)